so
um i'm sasha mazzo i'm a co-founder of a
company called new world machines i'm
actually not the scientific person i'm
not technical by background so the the
doctor in front of my name is actually
the first time i've seen that my dad
goes by professor so that that's sort of
a oh no it's it's it's like i feel like
it's a compliment but
um i've i've had a chance over the last
few years to learn a lot about solar
cooling we've
traveled down a certain path and i'll
tell you guys a little bit about it
because i think
part of what i want what i want to talk
to you about is also technology
development um so let me ask a couple
questions how many of you since it's an
engineering class how many of you guys
are thinking about
doing i don't want to make any
assumptions how many of you guys are
thinking about doing something related
perhaps to um
core scientific development around
you know new new climate technologies
basic sort of you know fundamental
r d and product development
startup
um how many of you guys are thinking
about doing something related
to
physical
technology meaning like a a machine
versus software so physical technologies
software
okay
um
policy are any of you thinking about
this from the standpoint of policy and
sort of from a broader perspective of
how do you tackle climate change and
okay
okay
any any other kind of burning reasons
that
that you're here just so i know
the audience it's really about sort of
understanding how these technologies can
be applied
all right so
hopefully what i'm going to do today i'm
going to talk a little bit about solar
cooling
focused um i don't know if you guys had
a chance to do the readings but the um
there's two fundamental ways of solar
cooling
and um
let's see
this is this is the one i'm going to
spend more time on so um two kinds of
solar panels
in the simplest form right there's
photovoltaics and and solar thermal
panels
solar thermal predates photovoltaic
voltaics at least in somewhat mass
adoption jimmy carter had them on the
white house before they were taken off
by ronald reagan um
this is true um
the um
solar thermal panel is a relatively
simple device right it's basically
uh it it doesn't have to convert into
electricity so you're simply heating
water
right so
the
we can get into the differences
fundamentally between the two panels but
but essentially
leading class photovoltaic panels
because they have to convert to
electricity they i believe are
optimally producing about 15 to 20
percent of the energy that's coming from
the sun they're converting 15 to 20
percent into electricity um a solar
thermal panel because it's really just
doing the work of taking heat from the
sun and turning it into some kind of a
heat storage is converting
60 of the energy okay we can also get
into how they're made there's a lot of
issues with how photovoltaics are made
and they've gotten cheaper and cheaper
and when you start to look at the
materials that they're comprised of
there have been a number of concerns
about their the impact the greenhouse
gas impact of how the things are
actually manufactured what goes into
them what goes into the production
processes a solar thermal panel is
pretty simple um
there's a couple different kinds
there's a flat plate well there's the
pool heater which is really just a sort
of a
plastic or rubber membrane it's very
simple
sun's energy goes through the
the heated rubber plastic material to
provide a modest amount of heating for
pools because you don't need that much
heat um the next step up is a flat plate
collector
which is sort of what's represented here
um
and
again without without having a deep
scientific knowledge of it
basically the construction is there's a
filament and and it's encased in in a um
on a
metal surface a reflective um surface
and
there's not there's not a lot of sort of
um
exotic materials that are going into the
construction of of the panel there's
evacuated tube panels which are then
in a vacuum
that adds to the thermodynamic
properties of retaining some of the heat
they have some advantages and
disadvantages again versus
flat plate collectors one of the
disadvantages that people
unclear whether it's a true concern but
they are concerned about is ice storms
and you know the potential for those
panels for the tubes to break under hail
or ice storm kind of conditions um
and then there are more complicated
solar thermal panels which
there's two kinds there's parabolic
trough and linear fresnel what those are
are
they they can
harness the sun's energy under an even
higher heat and they basically um
either in a parabolic fashion or or they
redirect it basically onto a focal point
much like sort of a an array of solar
panels does and so you can generate heat
at a higher temperature so that's very
basic kind of i'm going to cover a
couple things just to kind of get you
guys up to what solar cooling is so
so the idea basically of solar cooling
is you take
solar thermal panels so you heat up
water
and by heating up water you put it into
a chiller called an absorption or
adsorption chiller
i'll talk much more about this kind of
technology because that's basically what
we've redesigned
and then
the the chiller takes in heat it uses
that heat as energy so rather than using
electricity it's actually using heat
energy
it doesn't need heat from the sun it can
take heat from any source so
we're talking about other heat sources
being
gas fired so you can
it the machine takes hot water so you
have a storage tank and you need to heat
up the water in that tank so you could
actually take waste heat from a process
heating application let's say you're a
chemical factory you'll have waste heat
available that you could then convert
through a heat exchanger to hot water to
power the machine
so um absorption chillers are actually
used now primarily in industrial
applications because there is a
prevalence of sort of
high grade um high temperature waste
heat to to use for for cooling
um so this is the basic system
um everything except for the solar field
would be
basically the same
if you were using absorption chiller in
other applications so the only thing
that's different about it that makes it
solar is just adding solar thermal
panels to it
so
basically you know the idea here is
quite simple
at the point in the day when you have
sunlight you typically are generating
heat that that is heating up a building
or a ship or or
a vehicle and at that point in the day
your your
need for
cooling is also increasing so as you're
you know at 10 a.m you start to have
some some cooling gains
to the building and as you're moving
throughout the day
you're offset slightly but basically
there's a coincidence with the
sunlight of available sun to the the
need for cooling so with that overlap
the idea is that there's sort of this
elegant solution that if you had a
technology that could actually harness
the sun's energy at the point in the day
when you most need to cool the
environment
you you basically have a very elegant
way to provide cooling
now
i'm not going to get into this was off
of one of the reading sources there are
a number of different technologies that
basically is the chiller
also that you can use i'm not going to
dive a whole lot into this other than to
say that
but i'm thinking i may not be the only
one who's wondering
can you explain a little more about what
an absorption chiller does okay i i i
will beautiful
yeah that's actually what more of the
talk is going to be about because what
we've basically done is created a new
kind of absorption chiller so we'll
we'll dive deeper into that and
hopefully that'll be interesting for you
guys i just wanted wanted you to sort of
have a have a backdrop of solar cooling
um
so anyway there's a number of different
technologies out there it's a little bit
head spinning when you actually start to
dive into
how they work but
stepping back from it for for a second
i'll tell you that that absorption
chillers
um were invented in the 1850s by a
frenchman i believe his name is fernand
um the carray
he
so they predate vapor compression
chillers which are the machines that you
see on
buildings ubiquitously
so electric chillers came about at the
turn of the 20th century so these were
actually invented 50 years prior to that
so
um
we'll jump into it a little bit more but
um
so from the standpoint of you know
some some different thoughts on solar
cooling obviously buildings use consume
a significant amount of the energy in in
the built environment and
um 30 of their operating expenses are
spent on
on utilities
of that
space cooling is 15 percent of it
space heating is another
16 of it um refrigeration is seven so
you know these are significant so
if you were if you're if you were a
building manager let's say there's a
building manager for this building and
they've tried to make this building as
efficient as possible you're at stanford
you're trying to to basically have it as
efficient an environment as to set an
example for your students so you've got
more efficient lighting that's been
installed
and this these are still i think cfl so
there's there's
you know an opportunity to to upgrade
these to leds but you know the prices
have dropped considerably and so you
know there's led technology and that's
all going to become fairly ubiquitous
the next
big challenge in the building space is
how do you deal with air conditioning
heat and heating systems because they
consume
you know 35 to 40 percent of the energy
in the building and and as we optimize
the lighting systems they're they're
proportionally consuming more and more
of the energy because they're not as
optimally
built as lighting okay so
what's happened to air conditioning in
the last 30 years how how much better
has it gotten so this is what's very
exciting for me to talk to you guys
because i think there's a mandate here i
think
this area needs
problems that has a significant number
of problems need to be solved i think
there's real opportunity in the last 30
years this is ashrae which is the
governing body that sets the standards
for air conditioning and heating
equipment in the in the united states
these are their standards and what's
happened to them in the last 30 years
they've had a 30 improvement so
basically they're we're we've improved
our air conditioning by one percent
every year in the last 30 years okay so
if we're in a situation where we have
deep climate challenges
this is this is a huge problem
in that span we've gone from you know
we've gone to electric cars we've
incredibly downsized the the size of our
computers we've made huge advances in
lighting but air conditioning is has not
made dramatic
shifts forward okay so
let me now talk a little bit more about
what what our company is doing and and
talk about absorption chillers and kind
of how we've redesigned this
okay so
here's what's what
this is a campus that's probably you
probably have a central cooling plant
that cools throughout the campus however
in a typical office building um
you would have something like this you
know multi a mid-size or high-rise
building and have something like this so
you have a machine that creates the cold
and then you pump the cold through the
building so the machine is called a
chiller
you have an air handler that basically
is determining whether to
how to mix the air
in the building
and it's basically uh routing the the
air to fan coils throughout the building
you have a cooling tower because any
machine generates waste heat um a
chiller generates enough waste tea that
you actually have to get rid of get rid
of that heat in order for the machine to
operate efficiently so this is basically
a byproduct of the machine
this is what a typical absorption
chiller looks like
so
i guess
you know some
key points is it's obviously a
mechanical
machine there's
um
pumps and and um
you know large vessels that
um
basically
need to separate the different processes
and it actually doesn't look that
different from a vapor compression
chiller so these are you know old-school
mechanical machines that the the
way that this machine is designed hasn't
fundamentally changed in the last 100
years
is the fluid being condensed and
evaporated and absorbed is it always
aqueous
um
well in an absorption chiller
traditionally it's it's water and
ammonia and yeah or it could be a
lithium bromide and water machine
so yes
um
you know there's some other technologies
out there but for the in terms of an
absorption chiller yeah there's there's
all sorts of sort of different
permutations that
that we can kind of go down but i think
to simplify
um
so
i'm gonna i'm gonna dive into what our
company does and hopefully this is
interesting for you guys so we took this
this mechanical machine and turned it
into this
so um
all of the dials on the outside of the
machine essentially are just for reading
the performance of the machine
effectively it's a solid state chiller
so we've eliminated the pumps in the
machine we've we've effectively
eliminated the mechanical components
um
here's some side views of it
and i'll explain to you guys in a couple
minutes how the machine works at least
as a non-scientific non-technical person
um
in fact let me jump jump to that and
then i'll come back to its advantages so
what's going on inside this machine
there's
thin sheets of plastic they're several
millimeters thick and we're actually
cutting the cooling cycle directly onto
those sheets
okay so we call it a micro channel
it's basically a heat exchanger but it's
a micro channel design so the cooling
cycle is occurring on those thin sheets
and then you seal the sheets on either
side with a steel sheet so basically
you've got you've trapped the
fluid inside these sheets and then you
increase the capacity of the machine by
adding more and more sheets to it so we
call it an ice book like you know sheets
added to a book um
if we go back to
and so you can sort of see that this is
just a plexiglas in front of the on the
right
what the sheets this isn't very old
design but basically what they look like
inside the machine
so we've effectively eliminated all the
moving parts inside of this machine so
it's a total redesign of an absorption
chiller there's actually a new cooling
cycle as well
but
part of the elegance of this there's a
sort of a simplicity to it where we've
actually so the biggest
these machines have issues in terms of
their performance and reliability and
how much they cost to make and these are
some of the reasons why
if you run a given building and make
decisions about how to upgrade your
equipment you may choose not not to
purchase one of these machines
so um
we vastly simplified those different
things and also when you when you
simplify machine down to this you can
imagine when you're trying to
manufacture it this is much much simpler
to make
than
this
okay there's a lot of steel and there's
also
a lot of components that not only need
to be manufactured but then also when
you're looking at ongoing operation
operation and maintenance costs o m
which is a big concern for people who
manage buildings are are
significant okay
so um
so this machine um
how this all came about
are
leading lead inventor was in
um he's austrian he's from vienna he was
in tanzania and um working with he was
there with the austrian government he's
working with milk farmers and was seeing
milk spoiling on the way to market and
realize there must be some way to
avoid this kind of an issue in basically
an off-grid environment they don't have
reliable electric grid there so they
don't have a means of of basically
maintaining that milk at necessary
temperatures so not just milk there's a
lot of produce um spoilage and these are
issues that are that are prevalent in
developing countries and um also lead to
you know price gouging where the
middleman comes to you and says you can
sell it to me now or it's gonna spoil so
they so
um
so i want to talk about some other
applications that are not just solar
cooling just to sort of stimulate your
your thinking about this um but that was
the back story so then
what we did from an r d standpoint from
a from
the thermodynamic physicist who invented
this machine
started from the perspective that
that big bulky machine the manufacturers
have all tried to take that big machine
and keep trying to make it smaller and
smaller and in effect you still have all
of those moving mechanical parts and
when you make it smaller and smaller
it's still very expensive it still has
reliability issues and it's not
optimized so he started from
what's the smallest possible machine
that we can build and if we can build a
small machine we can actually scale up
from there okay so
this is sort of the path of invention
for the technology and he actually went
back to
thermodynamic principles that were from
the turn of the 20th century that are
about 100 years old in order to
generate some of the ideas that led to
this invention
okay so another interesting thing about
this machine so
typically when you have a chiller if
it's
you know one room you need a one-ton
chiller
a house you might need three tons four
tons a building you might need 500 tons
so typically you just build a bigger
machine in our case this is a bit like
servers on a server rack or like fuel
cells
we actually connect the machines in
series so that you instead of having one
large machine you basically could have
500 smaller machines we actually will
build them in five ton increments so for
a 500 ton system you'll have 100
machines that are working basically in
series
why is that interesting or why is that
of value um so those machines are then
going to be dynamically controlled so we
have a proprietary way of electronically
controlling them in series
so
most
air conditioning systems um
you have to you size them a system for a
building at stanford for probably a 95
degree day
the number of times that that occurs in
a year is perhaps once or twice so you
have a you have a chill around this
building that is designed in order to be
able to handle that load so those are
design conditions and you're actually
there's standards by by way you have to
design these things and so typically
chillers on buildings are way over
designed and so they spend most of their
life operating a part load so it's not a
cold day but let's say you were you know
in late spring or summer that your
machine your chiller would still be
operating at maybe 70 or 80 percent load
so the the challenge is how do you
optimize a chiller for that part load
performance these are very real issues
that are dealt with so when you have
chillers that are connected like this
you can actually dynamically control
them
another issue with startup with um
absorption chillers is they actually
start up really slowly there's something
about the the thermodynamics of the
machine that means that they start up
slowly so if if in this building you
need the air conditioning on demand
that's an issue um so we've solved that
again by having these
machines running in series because you
can keep one or two of them on a sort of
a low trickle and turn those on while
the other machines are heating up
the other thing is if if you put on the
hat of somebody who's potentially buying
the machine you're designing and they're
concerned about reliability and they're
concerned about buying a machine from a
brand new company um so we're always
thinking about that how do we
how do we deal with the challenge of um
you know the the customer and what what
issues they're going to bring forward
so you deal with reliability if one of
these goes down it's like a server farm
the rest of the servers are still alive
and they're able to function and you can
basically pull out this machine and
the overall chiller still keeps working
um i'm not going to go into this this is
this is
um
this is a thermodynamic representation
of the new cooling cycle within the
machine um and since i don't have a
thermodynamic background and this isn't
a thermodynamic course i'm not going to
dive into it but
there is sort of core science that's
different about the machine that allows
it to operate more efficiently
so i'm going to talk let's talk about
applications
actually
let me
jump jump here first okay so we talked a
little bit about solar thermal and
obviously the benefit of this is once
you've installed the system you
essentially have energy from the sun
that's free
now
you don't have to size the system we're
just keep using this building as an
example
you don't need to sign the size the
system for for 100 load of this building
you may not have enough roof space for
that but you could still take take some
of the load for the building and use
solar for that load
um you might have waste heat in this
building or there might be waste heat
nearby so you could actually supplement
that by also putting waste heat into the
system you can work use them in tandem
you might you might
decide to use gas as a way to heat the
machine versus electricity why would you
want to use gas versus electricity so
putting aside coal coal powered
power plants for the moment gas-powered
electricity generation stations or power
plants they only deliver about 30
percent of the energy that they consume
to the end user so when you get
electricity at the plug here it took you
know two and a half times that in terms
of consuming gas in order to generate
that electricity some of it is lost in
the production some of it is lost in the
transmission and
of the of the electricity so if you can
actually use gas directly at the source
and if you can use it with an efficient
chiller it's much more efficient than
burning gas in order to generate
electricity which then
you convert into cold okay so from a
from a engineering standpoint
trying to come up with the most elegant
solutions which is if you can take heat
energy and produce cold without having
to um convert it into electricity from
our point of view that that's a much
more elegant um way to solve the problem
so
let's talk a little bit about
applications
um
so
chillers are our big machine central
plants in the top left-hand corner that
you find on larger buildings
on on industrial applications and mid to
large sized
office buildings
the most of the machines
in the u.s most of the
cooling and heating is actually done by
what are called rooftop units which are
basically if you look at it if you look
at a shopping mall
on the roof you have multiple little
units even big box stores a walmart will
have eight or ten of these um
these are the least efficient um they
last
the they have the lowest lifespan
um the most
uh reliability issues but they also
happen to be the cheapest okay so
it's not really that surprising if you
think about that combination as to why
those are the ones that get installed
because these big box stores might be in
business for 10 or 15 years
that might be good enough for them or
that's the framework that they're
looking at and
cheap installation price and to be
honest they weren't that concerned about
how much money they were spending on
electricity on their monthly bills until
recently our energy costs in the us are
really low california's are twice a lot
of the u.s but the us generally is you
know half to
sometimes even a fifth what people are
paying in the rest of the world for
energy costs so these things are
ubiquitous that 80 percent of the
commercial buildings in the us have
those
and they're horribly inefficient um so
there's a lot of work being done to try
to solve that issue and our chiller can
actually work for that um obviously
there's also the issue of refrigeration
and ice making so
this is a you know i don't i don't know
what in total um
is the amount of energy that's consumed
but there's a there's a huge amount of
energy both in in terms of process so
all the industrial energy in
transporting refrigeration and ice
making um you know it's not just sort of
a you know grocery store uh consumption
of refrigeration
and then chp and micro chp i don't know
if you guys are familiar with combined
heat and power so this campus may have a
combined heat and power plant because
it's large enough you're shaking your
head so i'm guessing that's the case i
know for example working with uc davis
and they have a central plant so
basically the idea is you have a
location that's big enough that you can
have your own it's like a small power
station it takes gas in and generates
electricity and then it also generates
heat and
um it can potentially generate cooling
as well because again you've got heat
energy you can use it to power an
absorption chiller and we call that then
trigeneration so
a combined heat and power plants
typically you call it co-generation
because you're generating electricity
and you're also generating heat and then
when you add cooling to it it's
trigeneration
and then recently there are companies
including some in silicon valley that
are trying to do micro chp which are
basically like fuel cells that are again
offering um heating and uh electricity
from a fuel cell in a smaller
application where it doesn't have to be
a huge
college campus
other kinds of applications obviously
residential air conditioning so
transportation is an interesting one
most uh i think look i think both large
cargo ships and also cruise ships use
these combined heat and power plants so
they have um
readily available heat uh to provide
cooling obviously you know there's a lot
of refrigerated transport that's going
on um and then as i mentioned to kind of
come back to where this began um there's
an interest
for us there's an interest in off-grid
cooling because i think that
there are a lot of parts of the world
where that would be a game changer in
terms of both you know produce but also
you know there's there's critical
applications like hospitals and schools
where if you're able to provide cooling
to them that's going to make a
meaningful impact in terms of uh you
know the quality of life
so that's something that we're actually
as a company where
we have a non-profit arm called one
fridge which is loosely based on sort of
one laptop one child um
where we're looking at ways to bring
cooling applications to third world and
developing countries
off-grid uh through something like this
so basically the idea would be you could
take a cooling machine with a solar
panel on top of it without any kind of a
electricity power source and put that in
the middle of a remote location and
you'd have um cooling available so you
could do village cold rooms you could do
ice making in those applications um
you know so
there's also
you know whether
depending on where you're where your
orientation is um
uh for example you know the military in
afghanistan they're transporting jet
fuel in order to power generators in the
field so if you think about this you
know again in those kinds of
applications and often
the military tends to be
advanced in terms of bringing new
technologies to market they tend to be
real proponents of leading edge
technologies
so here's
just to kind of make it a little a
little more tangible for you guys here's
um this is in our
r d lab in australia um
here's the kind of cutting the sheets
the plastic sheets and the channels into
the sheets
and assembling them
layering layering them on
in the icebook
and this is the machine on a test bench
so we're we're just using
um
hoses basically off the shelf i think
they may even be garden hoses to
run water to the machine
um and these are the this is the
efficiency the performance curves of the
machine um
based on its rejection temperature is
the um
waste heat um
so
a critical a critical component here is
your waste heat temperature versus how
your ambient temperature your outdoor
heat temperatures beca the machine
operates more efficiently if you can get
rid of the waste heat from the machine
so if it's hot outside it's harder to do
that the
cooling tower has to work much
more aggressively in order to be able to
reject the heat so there's different
performance based on that
um and this is sort of the basic
configuration
of our machine
in a solar cooling system um
so the the ice box the is in the blue
and
um
you have a hot water tank so the machine
just takes hot water so basically you've
got a hot water tank and you use gas as
a backup so even if you had a solar
cooling system someone asked me uh one
of the questions was how do you use this
for high-rise buildings so the answer is
that you sort of use it in in tandem
with other heat sources you can use gas
or if it's available waste heat or you
may not actually put this on a building
um
as the only cooling source um let me
explain that in a second
so
in california we have tiered rates
so
your first increment of electricity
you're paying
not a very not a very high amount let's
say you're paying 8 cents a kilowatt
then you're paying 12 cents then
suddenly it jumps to tier three you're
paying 24 cents and then at the end of
the month you're using more and more
you're paying now 36 cents a kilowatt so
there's a huge difference
um in
the tier four price and your tier one
price so as a building manager you'd
like to try to save money and that's a
big incentive for them actually to to
reduce their electricity bill the
biggest drivers of of your peak load are
your air conditioning and in the winter
you're heating okay
so the idea our idea is if you
put one of these machines into a
building as a supplemental chiller so a
building has a 500 ton load you put a
machine in there that's 50 tons and
basically that's your first source of
cooling so you keep the existing chiller
on the building and you add this as a
supplementary chiller it's also can be
called a pony chiller you can actually
see huge reductions in your energy cost
because that machine now is
it's not powered by electricity so your
electricity bill is is
it's not gonna
the amount of electricity you're using
might only be 10 percent less but you're
going to save 30 or 40 on your utility
bill because it's expensive electricity
um
a lot of buildings this is a this is a
computer science building i would not be
surprised if there are rooms in this
building that
have they may be they may be server
farms like this where there's so much
heat that that room needs and even
though this building was presumably
designed from the ground up for this
purpose that that room needs more
cooling than the main system the
building is actually providing right so
that's a problem because what's
happening is your main chiller for the
whole building is being cranked up just
for that one room so it's incredibly
inefficient and this is very very common
in fact
i was talking to an office manager for a
big commercial developer a lot of
offices now are when they have vacant
space they're turning them into these
sort of server rooms because you can now
just sort of do cloud computing and
those kind of settings and they have
this this problem in office buildings so
our thought again is to provide
cooling you could do it in rack or you
could provide spot cooling to the room
use a small chiller it doesn't have to
be for the whole building but you use a
chiller that just works for that
specific room
and you're going to have a significant
savings on your utility bill because
you're not your main chiller is not
going going
crazy
um
i don't know if i want to talk about
i wanted to talk a little bit about
the market so when you're designing
technology have you guys come across
this idea from steve blank uh are you
familiar with who steve blank is
um okay
so this is one one of the key things
that's that we learn in the cleantech
open steve blank's a professor at
stanford um
he does this very interesting history of
silicon valley which is i recommend you
guys check out that it's online you can
find on youtube but what he's known one
of the things he's known for is for
getting out entrepreneurs quote unquote
out of the building so when you're
designing something making sure that
what what people what what um engineers
and entrepreneurs like to do is they've
got an idea they've talked to a couple
people and it seems pretty cool and
they've talked to their friends or their
co-founders and it seems pretty cool and
everybody's on the same page and what
they like to do at that point is
basically go and take the time to build
the machine or to build the the software
application and so they put a lot of
time and energy into that and what they
typically what typically happens is they
come out the other end and it turns out
they really haven't talked to the people
that they're trying their potential
customers so he's got a a very very um
it's it's a very important
um basically framework for
continually getting out of the building
and talking to your customers at every
step even before you build the thing to
figure out if what you're building
anybody's actually interested in
and so
from that point of view
particularly because
and you know so when when you go through
the cleantech open we actually spend a
bunch of time you try to talk to they
they encourage you to try to talk to
almost 100 customers and we're talking
about you know like managers of
buildings you know people who manage a
whole block of office portfolios i talk
to somebody you know who manages whole
foods stores talk to the hvac installers
talk to the people who um you know
residential customers from all sorts of
different um
markets
so
one of the things that i learned in that
process is that people who buy hvac
equipment are pretty risk-averse this is
they don't want the air conditioning
system on this building to break down
they they're not going to take a risk on
a brand new technology so
that's one of the reasons for for us as
a strategy that we didn't want to come
in and say replace your whole building
chiller we're more than happy to say try
out our system as a supplementary system
as an add-on because there really isn't
risk in that case you haven't you're
we're not asking you to take your own
system offline um
but
we identified you know they look at it
as there's technical because they don't
know if the new technology is going to
work and you guys are going to face that
with what you design there's also
financial risk because they don't know
if if it
actually performs as well as you say and
it's going to save you money
and there's a
adoption risk where
there they have tenants typically in
that building and those those tenants
don't want to hear that they've just put
on a new chiller and so for some reason
the building um is really hot and the
tenant should be okay with the fact that
we're trying a new green technology um
they they're responsible for the tenants
to keeping the system online all the
time
um
so
that's sort of what we've
that's kind of our approach so there's
more than just sort of the core
technology here there's figuring out how
you're going to get it in to market and
especially how are you going to get it
to market initially how are you actually
going to generate sales
um from the technology that you develop
so
you know
we so this was the approach to sort of
doing peak shaving and spot cooling as a
way to mitigate this risk
okay
so
i'm going to leave it there um
hopefully i touched on a couple
different things and i think you know if
there's i'd definitely welcome questions
and happy to field any any questions you
guys have
great thank you
i'm really glad that you touched on the
design process because we
we remember kimberly's uh
talk about design thinking earlier in
the quarter that this was a nice
tie-in you know if you if you're not
designing something the customer
actually wants
you know what good is it so that that
was really good i like i like the
business model a lot
folks
that this is this is revolutionary any
thoughts
i know it's late in the quarter and late
in the day
so so art chillers so i showed you the
efficiency graph so there's there's a
couple inputs in terms of the efficiency
yep so like like the other ones that are
like if you have a higher temperature
you're going to get more efficient
prices that's right
so
um
a traditional so this is a single effect
chiller single effect is basically
the cycle occurs once a double effect
chiller uses the waste heat
and reruns it through the chiller
so we've at this point we've built a
single effect machine we can actually
build a double effect machine off of
this platform but
we're calculating anything up up to
potentially a cop of 1.6
and right now the
single effect chillers
achieve a cop of
under 0.9 um
i think it's even less than that
yeah so it's about it it's
about 75 percent more efficient and the
key thing actually is so for solar
cooling um a little bit of the real
world of it um i described some
different kinds of solar thermal
collectors the ones that are
most affordable and reliable are the
flat plate and evacuated tube collectors
and those are the ones that
um you know there's companies in europe
that make them and
they're easy to obtain but also there's
chinese manufacturers that make them and
there's whole cities in china that have
get their domestic hot water from solar
thermal
same thing with israel i think in israel
it may be mandated to in residential
applications to get
domestic hot water from solar thermal
so if we can
have a chiller that runs at lower
input temperatures
which which qualifies for those kinds of
collectors that's sort of the magic
bullet
a lot of folks in the solar thermal
industry have been trying to find a
chiller that works well at low input
temperatures because those other kinds
of collectors
there are some companies out there that
make them but it's been very tough for
those companies to get market traction
because they're really only used for a
couple applications like this solar
cooling and then maybe process heating
they've had a really tough time a lot of
those companies startups have failed
it's been very difficult for them to get
traction whereas
the companies that make flat plate and
evacuated tubes they're they're
run-of-the-mill they're they're easily
available off the shelf so getting a
making a chiller that has a driving
temperature so the input temperature
into the chiller is low enough so let's
say 170 60 160 degrees fahrenheit
is kind of the key thing and then having
the chiller perform efficiently
does that make sense
speaking of the economics do you guys
have
done any studies on the feedback time so
you said that you can
kind of cut off
one of your
expenses but you have any estimates
yeah yeah we have i didn't bring those
numbers um yeah maybe i didn't bring the
financials but the um
it depends on the kind of system so if
it's a solar cooling system the payback
is a little bit longer um but you get a
bigger payback in the lifetime of the
system right um so i think with
a solar system and and there's a host of
variables so one of the big variables is
how much solar radiation do you get at
your location so if it's phoenix arizona
um versus europe so the irony is that
europe has
generally the solar radiation of alaska
right so this is the irony that europe
is so much further ahead in solar
adoption than the us because we have
much more solar radiation um
but
uh you know in phoenix arizona you could
look at potentially a four to five year
payback on a solar cooling system
and you could look at a
the scenario that i gave you that's from
from my point of view the best payback
this idea of sort of a supplemental
chiller because
um where electricity rates are high
um and if you can shave off um you know
that peak rate you could be looking at
you know one year or two year um
paybacks even potentially on a solar
cooling system because it's a small
system and it's you know the the
electricity you're paying that you're
now saving at that rate is is so high um
now if the system if we
set up a system that was running on
waste heat so if you had a building that
was generating a lot of waste heat
payback is much sooner because you don't
have to put on the solar panels and the
racking and piping from the from the
solar panels so if it was only powered
by waste heat
and and then also with gas the payback
could could also potentially be much
sooner because gas is about
a third the price per unit of energy of
electricity
um
so
are you targeting data centers that
would be pretty obvious well
the waste heat from data centers is not
high enough it's a pretty it's a very
low grade waste seat i mean it's the
most elegant example right i think it's
the one i use with people initially
right this idea that the the biggest
problem in a data center is to get rid
of its heat so if you actually take that
heat and turn it into cooling you'd have
a virtuous cycle right so that's that's
sort of the basic example with solar
cooling i think that's that's it as a
framework that that's the easiest way to
think about it um the challenge is that
computers don't generate 150 or 160
degree heat because they'd melt the
servers
so there is a slightly counter-intuitive
way to go about this that i think we
need to model out you could actually
potentially
get a heat pump to
heat to take that heat and increase it
to the point where then you could use it
for cooling right so you basically be
adding heat to the system it's a little
counter-intuitive but if you had enough
heat then then you could actually power
the the cooling so it that could be a
possibility
yeah
they put their servers in different
offices to heat up the offices
so you can have your own services yeah
you know
if they if they trust if they have a
yeah they trust people in that office
not to oh i mean yeah if they can't
survive
i mean i think that's that's smart you
know i read that um
something like a third of the energy um
that we consume
uh
let's say just for heating and for
process heating so process heating and
heating is about 40 of the energy that's
consumed and it's something like a third
of it
is basically dumped as waste heat
so you know there is a challenge and
sort of how to capture that and if it's
low like super low grade wasted like
from a computer which we have a lot um
or usable for our system which would be
like 150 degrees on up
or you know in industrial processes
where it's quite a bit higher
yeah are you doing any r and d to try to
reduce the capital cost of the system
um so so that's the key um
the the system is designed from from the
beginning to try to basically
um reduce its
capital cost compared to a vapor
compression chiller not so the system's
going to be less expensive than uh
traditional absorption chiller
um traditionally absorption chillers
actually cost on a you know per
installed ton basis they cost somewhere
between
they're about three times more expensive
than a vapor compression chiller which
is a big difference and
it's it is one of the reasons why their
adoption
is not nearly as high
it uh so
what we're trying to do is compete with
vapor compression trailers with electric
chillers with the ones that are
ubiquitous because that's that's really
what we need to do um and so
we're
everything we're doing now is focusing
on optimizing the um manufacturing to do
it so that's the idea is get rid of all
the mechanical components
you know simple sheets that you know
you're either etching or laser cutting
and stamping
um you know simple assembly of the
components yeah those are the critical
things
again from an engineering perspective
from from the standpoint of how to
design it initially you know how where
to think about the problem um in terms
of
what your cost customer needs so if an
absorption chiller is three times more
than a vapor compression chiller you
know
the cost of energy has to be so much
higher uh for them to
uh for for a customer to make the choice
and the problem is also that they're not
as efficient
um so that that's where we're sort of
making a leap both in terms of cost and
in terms of efficiency
what's the current scale of
manufacturing do you think that
kind of like you saw with with solar as
the scale of manufacturing went out the
cost came down yeah quite dramatically
because that's something you guys are
yeah commenting on it's going to be like
a current scale for me
the current scale is pre-production
right what we're doing right now we're
sending um in the next
month or so we're going to send a unit
to
again one of the key things in
industries like hvac you need
independent verification of the
performance of the technology so we're
sending a machine to oak ridge national
labs and they're going to test it they
have phds and absorption cooling that
they'll test it
and that's an important sort of step in
the process
and by the way labs like that actually
work can work with you to help optimize
the machines for manufacturing as well
so they can be a great resource in other
ways too
they have you know some of the largest
super computers in the world um
but
at scale it will the cost will
definitely come down i mean it's
basically like the plasma tv
metaphor you know they were ten thousand
dollars a few years ago and now they're
500
so you know this is even that was even
true for you know
such a large sort of you know widely
entered industry from so many different
players
yeah um but see the
in terms of how to get from startup mode
to product maturity that's that's the
key right and that's where this for us
this strategy of doing supplemental
cooling where we can save the most money
even if the machine is three times more
right now than what it would be when we
mass manufacture it and we still offer a
savings to to customers and people who
are going to be the early adopters
yeah i mean that's it's key in fact
there was a
venture capitalist from cosla who i was
speaking with and he from his point of
view
he pointed out that
most
clean tech technologies that have
actually been able to cross the valley
of death you know this idea from uh okay
so that they have basically been able to
find some market where despite the fact
that they're supe they're they're
they're much higher
costs than they will be at scale that
they're still going to be competitive so
they found some way whether it was
incentives for solar panels in germany
and spain or you know some way tesla
with batteries um
in order to to bridge that valley so
there has to be some
way means of
attacking the market where you can still
be cost competitive and compelling to to
customers who want to save money not
just be green so i'm wondering can you
maybe you're considering it do the sort
of solar city
model i know that helped us get solar on
our roof was this these blended lease
buy options we are considering it we're
considering we're considering this also
the idea of cooling as a service so the
idea that you would not sell people to
machine you would sell them cooling yes
um
so
it's a little bit trickier than
solar because
solar is a foot photovoltaic you you
offer them electricity so it has
multiple uses cooling cooling so our
machine actually i failed to mention
this so an absorption chill is a heat
pump so you can run it in reverse and it
provides heating
so our machine will actually be roughly
twice as efficient as other combustion
heaters
so
absorption chillers aren't usually used
as heaters because they're not that
efficient but we're actually looking at
again so if
you have the machine you can use it all
year round those kinds of rooftop
applications so basically in heating
season you you reverse it and you can
provide heating it at a cost savings as
well
well i don't want to um i don't i don't
want to um
talk specific numbers at this stage
because we're still pre-production i
mean we're what we're targeting is a
cost a capital cost per per ton just for
the chiller
that'll be competitive with vapor
compression chillers
yeah
that's that's our goal um
and i and i think we can do it um
because of the again the the simplicity
and elegance of the design
you know
i think that's a tough tough question
still for us at this stage because we're
pre-production in terms of the materials
and you know all of the you know the
bill materials that we've as we've added
it up i think we're
um i i think if we simply scaled it up
in terms so you know working with a
manufacturing partner that can do sort
of large scale manufacturing of it i
think we're probably
not that far off there's still some
optimizing we can do with the materials
um you know some of these things depend
on
quote unquote space age materials right
like the plastics have to withstand
certain temperatures
so that you're using plastic and those
sheets versus steel
yeah
those are some of the considerations
yeah that's really exciting thank you so
much sure oh sorry
if you wanted to build like a
business like solar city you'd get
subsidies as well from california or
something like that or you do
so there's there's substances subsidies
at different levels there's a database
that'll make your head spin a little bit
called d-s-i-r-e um desire which tracks
it's somebody maintains it out of north
carolina they track incentives around
the country so there's like there's
incentives at a federal level there's
instead of us at a state level there's
utility incentives there's some
municipalities have incentives and
when any given customer comes to you
sort of try to figure out so that's why
they have this database which is helpful
um yeah so so they're incentives um
in different countries the trick again
with a business like this um is you
don't want to build it relying on the
incentives you have to be cost
competitive without them because like
spain and germany found out you know
those incentives can change overnight
and you don't want to um basically
lose your whole sort of fundamental
business model because the incentive's
not there
that's right that's right
that's right that's right um and there's
some incentives right now in california
for solar thermal um the california
solar initiative called csi um it has
um they put aside a certain amount of
money for different things the
photovoltaic money i think has already
been used up
um and the solar thermal has not been as
aggressively used up the solar thermal
industry is having just
whether or not this is of interest to
you guys but it's having challenges
because pv is sort of sexy pv is the
thing that everybody seems to be putting
in
um
there are a number of other incentive
programs that are out there that'll
align for pv
and um the price of gas came down and so
the biggest the biggest issue for for
solar thermal panels is a low price of
gas because that's what they're
competing against that's where the end
users trying to make a decision about
how much money they can save so
we're in the position where we can use
the gas so
low-cost gas is not necessarily a bad
thing for for a chiller um but it's
really tough for the solar thermal
industries so
you know these are the this is sort of
like the realities that you're dealing
with when you're thinking about um how
to design a
environmental
cleantech technology
okay thank you so much
you